let's go next to our caller from the
2:01 area code caller from 201 tell us
who you are and what's on your mind
today hi good afternoon David my name is
Christian and I'm from New Jersey right
across Manhattan great and my question
was actually more of a free trade
question having taken microeconomics
you're told that free trade essentially
has more access to goods for more people
and therefore the prices soared because
of a bigger market right and then one of
the trade offs for protectionism is the
fact that you not only lose access to
these job sorry to these goods but that
you're able to ultimately protect jobs
however my teacher said that it's
basically consensus among economists
that these jobs eventually will be lost
anyway due to innovation and technology
right and I was wondering what your take
on that was it seems to me that the
progressive left is very much anti free
trade but if put into this context is it
really that that right so basically what
you're pointing out is the difference
between economics in the hypothetical
world of the totally rational actor and
perfectly open and free markets versus
applying the reality of the fact that
we're talking about people right so
Daniel Kahneman has has a lot of his
work is based on this it's based on the
starting point is hey on paper free
trade allows people to have more access
to goods because of specialization and
bringing in things that other people can
produce and it reduces cost and it makes
things more accessible great that's
rational economics then Daniel Kahneman
says well let's apply how the real world
actually works and the world of politics
the world of psychology the world of
sociology and anthropology etc and it
doesn't actually end up working that way
so I think that the I it's a really good
starting point to start with with what
you and I were taught and our you know
we're being taught in a class like
microeconomics but then we really need
to get into
the behavioral economics elements that
modify this because it doesn't actually
end up working that way I see and you
might explaining or elaborating a little
bit more into how why might not end up
working that way
oh I mean there's and it depends on
specifically you know this would be an
entire show but for example there's wide
consensus that you can change the
significant economic decisions by people
based merely on the wording of how you
present a scenario right and so even
though you could present two equivalent
economic scenarios in sort of the net if
you present scenarios as either gains
versus avoided losses you will get
drastically different responses and if
you believe in rational economic actors
that shouldn't happen right so this is a
really good topic it's a really in-depth
topic but but I think that maybe
something for a long-form investigation
for us at some point okay thank you all
right thanks so much for the call very
much appreciate it and on that note we
will take a break and continue what is
it is Thursday but it's kind of like a
Friday show we'll be back after this